ثلاثه اشهر كانت صعبه على المتداولين في
السوق السعودي تحديدا شهر نوفمبر كان
الاعنف بس احنا كل يعني النتائج او
النتائج الجيده اللي تحققنا عن بدايه هذا
العام عدنا الى مرحله الصفر او يعني
تقريبا السوق اليوم لم يوجد هناك
اي تحرك يعني اللي حدث كان هناك نزول
الحاد خلال شهر او شهر ونصف السبب يعود او
اهم الاسباب اللي موجوده هي ارتفاع اسعار
الفائده تاثرت بشكل كبير على حركه السوق
ولاحظنا هناك انخفاض حاد لاحظنا هناك عدم
رغبه في عمليات
لابد من تخفيف الكتابات نوع الماء لغايه
السوق يهدى اكثر ويستعد الثقه اكثر في
المستثمرين حجم لكتاب الضخم جدا شركات
عملاقه تدرج وهذه هذه هذه الكتابات تسحب
السيوله عاليه من السوق
البدائل الاخرى التي ظهرت مؤخرا بشكل كبير
جدا مثل الصكوك التي طرحتها البنوك وجمعت
مبادئ كبير 10 مليار للراجحي همم ايضا
نبارك كبيره بالفرنسي والاهلي وغيرها
[موسيقى]
تصور ان هناك عمليه تشبع في النزول هناك
عدم رغبه من الافراد في عمليه البيع او
الشراء لاحظنا هناك سلوك مغايره مختلف عن
مكان عليه في السابق كنا نرى عمليات هبوط
جماعي بالنسبه للدنيا ونرى ضغط في عمليه
السيوله لكن اليوم
منخفضه في عمليات بيوعي يعني تعتبر نوعا
ما معقوله ولا نرى تدافع في عمليات البيع
اتصور انها هي نهايه الخابطه
[موسيقى]